Makers is essentially about the science
of why we like what we like and one of
the most interesting answers to that
question is Maya m,
a y,
a most advanced yet acceptable,
and this was the theory of everything by
Raymond Loewy,
the father of industrial design in
America,
and a lot of people today don't know who
Raymond Loewy is,
but this is a guy who was essentially
kind of like Steve Jobs meets don draper
for the 19 fifties.
He invented or designed the first.
I'll go back.
He designed a the most famous car
designer,
the 20th century,
the 1950 studebaker,
the modern train,
the modern Greyhound bus,
the modern tractor.
Even that pencil sharpener that looks
like an egg.
That was his design,
and in thinking about this question,
how could one person understand what
consumers want from things as different
as cars and pencil sharpeners?
His answer was this Maya,
most advanced,
yet acceptable.
People are torn between neophilia.
On the one hand they like new things and
neophobia on the other hand,
they're afraid of anything that's too
new and he was this genius.
Essentially.
It combining familiarity and surprise.
I think the most useful way to think
about the Maya principal is to think of
it as to sell something familiar,
make it surprising,
but you sell something surprising.
Make it familiar,
so let's take an example like star wars.
George Lucas was working on star wars
for a long,
long time.
The script was absolutely terrible.
He was sharing it with his best friends
like Francis Ford Coppola,
and they were all telling him that the
script was absolute garbage and he had
essentially built this incredibly
surprising novel new world filled with
jet eyes and forces and magic and
creatures that no one had seen before.
And then he was reading this book by
Joseph Campbell on the mono myth on this
idea that every great story in human
history has essentially been the same
story of an ordinary person who goes on
an extraordinary journey.
Defeats a nemesis,
intimately involved in his own origin
story,
and then comes back to the real world as
the hero.
And so we said,
oh,
this is it.
This is the story that explains that as
Jesus.
That is Buddha,
that is the odyssey and the Iliad.
I'll take this incredibly familiar
structure and I'll put it into this
incredibly surprising world building
exercise and that is star wars.
It essentially sells and incredibly
surprising world in incredibly familiar
narrative setting and I think that's one
reason why we like it.
It's not so much that it's novel.
Instead,
it's a novel setting that is essentially
telling the oldest story known to man so
it matters where you're starting.
If you're starting with an incredibly
familiar product or a really familiar
intellectual property like say movies
and creating a movie sequel.
The challenge for those writers is how
do we create a surprising new story that
will get people to a familiar character?
Right?
But lots of people are dealing with the
opposite problem.
They have a new idea and they're trying
to make it familiar to an audience.
And the best example is from here all
come from technology.
I think about,
uh,
the,
the first apple macintosh where Steve
jobs famously said,
I need the screen to say hello.
I need it to look like a face.
He's creating an entirely new product
category that people aren't really used
to.
And so he understands how critically
important it is to take something that
is novel and to sell it through
familiarity.
This is a friend you see the exact same
thing I think with ai assistance.
Things like Alexa have a lilting female
voice,
which you could argue is a sort of
working with a gendered expectation of
an assistant,
but it's still working in the same
principle to sell a really new
technology,
like a little nub that has ai
intelligence inside of it.
Make it talk just like you would expect
an assistant to talk to you.
I think about this issue also with the
iphone.
Most famously,
you know,
Steve Jobs was not creating a product
category,
but he did create the most profitable
product in modern human history.
And it's important to remember that the
iphone did not look new.
It looked like a touch ipod.
It looked exactly like a product that
apple already had.
So when people picked it up,
they didn't have to think,
oh,
I don't know how to use this.
How does it work?
He essentially took an information
ecosystem that they understood and said,
now it also does calls and Internet and
so I think that it's really important
when selling a new product,
when taking a new idea and trying to
make it appealing,
trying to make it popular to not think
about making that surprising idea as
surprising as possible because people
love to be surprised.
No,
take the surprising idea and make people
feel comfortable with it,
make it feel like home,
make it feel familiar.
And so I think it's also interesting to
juxtapose this idea with google glass,
which is Google's sort of famously
flopping product where it looked like
spectacles kind of,
but they had like a huge cube here.
The point is that I think one of the big
problems with Google glass is that it
looked like a prototype.
It looks like a toy for nerds and in
fact I went to x rays and lane wrote a
cover story about X.
I've talked to a lot of people who
worked on Google glass and they said the
biggest problem with its rollout is that
we had a prototype for nerds and we sold
it as a product for consumers and that
was a mistake.
We told people that this is the new
iphone,
that this is the new product category
that's going to redefine the way that we
interact with computers and the
Internet,
but that's not really what it was.
It was a nice tool for manufacturing and
construction workers to put something on
that looked like goggles and record
their work and send it back to
supervisors,
but stop for two seconds and think who
wears goggles on a daily basis.
No one people wear glasses,
but google glass didn't look like
glasses.
They looked like Weirdo goggles and so I
think that it's really important when
trying to introduce new product category
to think as clearly as possible.
How do I make this feel as familiar to
its core audience as possible?
Particularly when it's a bright new idea
and I think the Google failed
tremendously in that,
in that aspect because they didn't
understand properly enough.
The habits and the familiarities of the
people that they were ultimately selling
to.